what kind of pets will your favorite
superheroes have I jumped at the
opportunity obviously there's a
there's a talk about when it comes to DC
credible cast alone is a is to get us
excited there are also tons of hilarious
behind the scenes moments Tick-Tock
challenge has gone wrong and some
impeccable improv will be digging into
number one we love to see it Vanessa
Bayer who voices PB isn't afraid to do a
few improvised moments for the sake of
comedy and I was really going off about
how into Wonder Woman I was I was able
to sort of just riff and riff and riff
the director Jared Stern gave Vanessa a
lot of freedom when it came to the
comedic aspects of her character when it
came down to finding pb's voice her love
of Wonder Woman was the driving force
behind it she even showed up to record
in a Wonder Woman cape and tiara
honestly she's exactly like me oh my
gosh Wonder Woman has sat like right
where I'm sitting number two speaking of
improv Vanessa Bayer wasn't the only one
to go off script the comedic Legend
Kevin Hart had a great time improvising
his own lines though he doesn't hesitate
to give credit to the writers he said
they provided a great skeleton to go off
of without that you have nothing so
giving me just something to play with
and utilize as a as a good starting
point number three all unless you're
Kevin Hart I think I probably did all of
my stuff 20 minutes though everyone else
spent hours in the booth the actors did
enjoy their time recording seeing the
end result is a big part of the reason
why Kevin actually prefers voicing
animated characters to Real Life Studio
acting he particularly loves watching
his character come to life things that
are unexpected that they add from your
actions when you're in a booth there's
nothing more fun number four
King of the booth let's talk about where
the voices came from the voice comes
mirror deep down in here you can't
explain it it's like an X Factor the
actors were given direction from Jared
Stern on how to find and capture the
voice of their characters obviously
Keanu Reeves absolutely killed it when
trying to hone in on his Batman voice
his Batman and his Batman voice I am the
Batman psychotic number five Bromance
anyone when Dwayne Johnson talks about
his character crypto's relationship with
Ace voiced by Kevin Hart he definitely
gets a little bit sentimental it's
honestly not too dissimilar to the
relationship that I actually have with
Kevin they truly know each other so well
that it's easy for them to bounce jokes
off one another we know each other's
cadences we know each other's tones I
think that there's a nice little comedy
seesaw number six this concept of the
superhero Peg goes all the way back to
1962. the concept of DC League of Super
Pets is Loosely based on the Legion of
Super Pets which was a team of animals
that first appeared in Adventure Comics
all of the characters were Peppers
throughout the series individually with
crypto only showing up at the very end
number seven we've got a super cast
behind the voices of these Super Pets
I'm decently funny in the movie but
everyone else I mean it's just home run
after home run after home run not only
is the cast full of brilliantly funny
actors but a lot of them have
experienced work together this will be
Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart's fifth
film collaboration together Keanu Reeves
and Kate McKinnon have been in three
animated films prior and Natasha Leone
and dashka Polanco have worked together
on Orange Is the New Black and Russian
doll it's hard not to have high
expectations when you've got such a
brilliant cast behind these characters
number eight Janu Reeves as Batman is
absolutely legendary he describes the
feeling of receiving the initial phone
call where he was asked to voice the
character as a good day I always wanted
to play Batman I mean I love the
character the comic book character and
all of the incarnations of the character
Keanu spent a lot of time on his own
when recording his lines he didn't even
cross paths with Dwayne or Kevin
number nine we can't get enough of
Batman over here Jared Stern wanted to
take the character in a completely
different direction in an interview with
the direct he opens up a bit about his
thought process behind the character you
know he's a he's just sort of a little
bit lost in this kind of crazy eyes and
he's still Batman he still kicks butt
but he's still an awesome superhero but
he's just he's seen some stuff in his
life and most importantly for our movie
he's a guy that could really use a pet
number 10 speaking of something special
let's talk about a goofy behind the
scenes moment I slept
in between recording Dwayne and Kevin
decided to do the infamous tortilla slap
challenge I think he wanted to kill me
all right Kevin was definitely a bit
terrified when it was his turn to get
slapped because Dwayne had his whole
hand behind the tortilla no that's not
how you doing judging by the captured
photo of the event it does seem like
Kevin may have had a point I'm telling
you so evil like he really sometimes I
think he wants to hurt me man number 11.
something every dog owner truly wonders
about when preparing for his role as
crypto Dwayne had just come off of
filming Black Adam which really helped
him get into the superhero mindset Kevin
took a bit of a different approach
Kevin's used to licking his own anyway
like dogs aside from that Kevin utilized
his own dog's unique personalities as
part of his research I talked to him I
got a response and it put me in a place
mentally where I was able to step into
the world of Ace number 12. definitely
the
villain we've seen green yet Kate
McKinnon's inspiration behind her
adorable antagonist comes from the movie
lady in a cage from the 1960s she's like
I am trapped in small private elevator
in case you haven't seen the film
definitely check out the trailer at the
end of this video I thought oh an evil
guinea pig would probably sound like
that
number 13 we're not talking about the
breakfast kind the character waffles is
actually a pretty big deal because he's
voiced by actor Sean Lee who will now be
known as the first Malaysian actor to
voice a character in an animated DC film
in an interview with August man we
learned a little bit about how Sean Lee
pictures Waffle's backstory he created a
backstory for the character by
envisioning waffles as a brutally honest
dog hailing from subang Jaya Malaysia as
a zubong boy himself he knew he had to
put his own spin on the character
embodying the perfect Malaysian dog
number 14 probably the most surprising
thing that took place behind the scenes
of course Kevin gives him a good
roasting for letting his kids miss their
most family-friendly film
Ed his kids are here okay it makes me
feel bad and guilty because my kids on
him the rock does give us a good reason
for it though his kids were picking up
their own Super pet named turbo kids are
adopting dogs what are your kids doing
right now number 15. uh yes please there
were actually a lot of Concepts and
characters that were cut from the final
film in an interview with Screen Rant
Jared Stern talks about using those
scrap sequences for a potential super
pet series I was like but that would be
good for a sequel if we ever were so
lucky to have one so yeah there
definitely is stop and there's a ton of
amazing fun animal characters in the DC
Canon and we couldn't fit all of them
into this movie clearly this movie
speaks volumes because of its all-star
cast The Incredible chemistry between
Kevin Hart and Dwayne The Rock Johnson
and the dedicated storytelling from
director Jared Stern which Super pet are
you most excited about